Tại vì thêm hội nghiệp về giải pháp hàng nhận nước bên lề phía học gấp cao đã hội đồng lý được quốc cả như yếu.
Hàng loa đồng tháng ngoại sao? Cho thấy suy own của tây đăng gia tăng dụng hộ công nhận nước Palestine.
Chúng tôi đẹp đạm với tổng thống pháp em ở Nguyên Mà Khrong.
Tổng thống ái cập mạm trên và tà nguồn gỡ gì gì nhấn mạnh.
Bây công nhận nhận nước Palestine là bất đi tình thiết.
Đồng thời kêu khỏi dự trình đường biến dưới năm 2019,
với đông dưới rút xa lem là tủ đô.
Truyền thông mang cho biết, tủ tổng kia xa mừng sẽ sống tuyên mố công nhận Palestine.
Chúng kê thủ tổng, cân đề mắc khăn đi khần định,
ô thông qua sẽ thiêu đổi kế hoạch này trong tổng tử ý.
Nhưng bất đi đồng thuận tư phương tay đu đánh giá là có thể tạo xức em ngoại sao đáng kể.
Tuy nhiên thực liệu lại tí tục bất đồn.
Thì yên xo ran tăng tưởng tổng tổng tại ca ra,
khi nhớ sống mình người tịt mạng chỉ trong một ngày.
Các quan sát cho rằng giữa bố cạnh căng thẳng hiện nay,
để cuối tệ tục đẩy công nhận nhận với Palestine,
mangến nghĩ ở chính lợp, lời với trên bạm hoa bình trung đông.